[Musique]
vous n'y prêtez peut-être pas attention
pourtant la géographie fait partie de
nos vies
au quotidien nous l'utilisons sur nos
smartphones pour trouver un chemin un
itinéraire
pour les armées c'est un peu pareil
analysez le terrain savoir se repérer
naviguer ses compétences sont
strictement liées à l'art de la guerre
sciences complexe la géographie
militaire occupe une place décisive dans
la sphère opérationnelle la France
compte parmi les rares pays à disposer
d'une chaîne complète de l'acquisition
d'information depuis l'espace ou sur le
terrain à la production de données un
atout quel exploitent chaque jour
ce mois-ci le journal de la défense
relève un défi inédit faire parler les
cartes
comme tous les militaires les aviateurs
utilisent de la cartographie les données
géographiques sont parfois même insérées
directement au sein des systèmes de
préparation de l'avion
dans la nuit du 13 au 14 avril 2018
elles ont été déterminantes ce soir-là
Washington Londres et Paris lance
Hamilton une opération sous commandement
français qui a pour objectif de détruire
le stock d'armes chimiques de Bassar et
al-Assad en Syrie
la France engage en l'air une vingtaine
d'avions dans une mission nocturne de
plus de 10 heures couvrant plus de 7000
km le commandant romain se souvient de
ce raid hors norme
cette opération a été préparée depuis
des mois et dans le détail sur les
derniers jours pendant
jour et nuit en fait pour l'âge 24 on a
plusieurs équipes qui se relayaient pour
se passer pour suivre la situation
l'évolution de la situation évolution
également de la météo pour ensuite avoir
une mission qui est prête et la mettre à
jour la comprendre et également préparer
toutes les trajectoires des missiles au
total 12 missiles de croisière sont
tirés depuis les airs et la mer avec une
précision quasi chirurgicale mais c'est
le croisière a une charge militaire mais
il va pouvoir avoir une phase de vol
quand on arrive suffisamment proche
d'objectifs on peut le tirer donc le
laisser tomber lui-même a un moteur pour
voler c'est un mini avion qui va aller
porter cette charge militaire jusqu'à
l'objectif et donc on va pouvoir choisir
par où il passe choisir son profil de
vol et de lui-même va trouver sa cible
et aller frapper dessus
et pour cela les informations
géographiques sont capitales c'est la
donnée essentielle la connaissance du
terrain de valquial on va devoir opérer
et vu qu'on est on fait nos missions à
des centaines et des milliers de
kilomètres de la France et bien on peut
pas observer le terrain comme ça donc on
se passe sur les données géographiques
sur les données de renseignement pour
pouvoir comprendre l'environnement dans
lequel on va devoir aller et préparer
tout cela ici au sol puisque c'est pas
une fois dans l'avion qu'on doit
découvrir le terrain
une bonne connaissance du terrain
représente un atout opérationnel
indéniable pour délivrer de l'armement
mais aussi parfois pour se soustraire à
la menace un autre type de mission qu'on
effectue ici à Saint-Dizier c'est le
suivi de terrain donc ce qui consiste à
voler de manière automatique proche du
sol dans toute condition qui le fasse
beau qu'on soit dans les nuages donc
pour cela l'avion a besoin d'un fichier
terrain qui lui est chargé dans son
ordinateur et grâce à fichier terrain et
à sa localisation qu'il connaît en temps
réel il est capable de d'appréhender ce
qui ce qui là autour de lui et donc de
déterminer ça autour de vol de manière
totalement automatique ce qui permet
pour nous d'avoir un avantage tactique
de rentrer ambassade d'altitude pour
être le plus le plus discret par rapport
aux ennemis
les données géographiques sont utilisées
par près de 90% des systèmes d'armes en
service et la plupart d'entre elles
proviennent de l'EGI l'établissement
géographique intermarmé situé sur la
base aérienne 110 de Creil il a été créé
donc en 2008 et dans son intérêt de
création sont définis ces missions ces
deux missions principales qui sont la
première une mission opérationnelle qui
a vocation de valider de gérer de
diffuser et de produire de la donnée
géographique au profit des forces la
deuxième mission qui est une mission
plus technicoopérationnelle qui est une
mission d'expertise qui se traduit par
le fait que l'établissement et le centre
militaire directeur de la géographie un
domaine qui a évolué au fil des années
en fonction des besoins des armées que
la question qu'il faut se poser de la
géographie mais pourquoi faire donc il y
a un premier besoin qui a un besoin sur
Historique un peu besoin traditionnel
c'est la carte papier c'est
l'information géographique qui va être
interprétée par un être humain ça veut
dire que vous avez une carte papier une
impression la donnée géographique est
dessus vous avez une légende là des gens
de vous permet de comprendre ce qui est
sur et c'est l'être humain qui va faire
l'interprétation en disant ça c'est une
route ça c'est un une zone urbaine etc
le deuxième besoin c'est un besoin qui
est émergé plutôt dans les années 90 où
là on a eu besoin à ce que des systèmes
d'armes consomment de la géographie on
avait des avions des hélicoptères des
missiles qui avaient besoin d'avoir de
la géographie pour pouvoir se
positionner dans l'espace et atteindre
leur cible de cas échéant dernier besoin
c'est un besoin qui a plutôt hébergé et
qui a plutôt émergé pardon au niveau de
des années 2000 où là on a eu un besoin
de flux de données
une centaine de personnes civiles et
militaires des trois armées travaillent
à l'EGI parmi les spécialités
représentées des géographes des
interprètes images des informaticiens et
même des photogrammènes
leurs tâches consiste à restituer les
prises de vue aériennes en modèle en 3
dimensions ce qu'on cherche à réaliser
ces deux saisir chaque élément avec le
plus de précisions possible qui est liée
forcément à la qualité de nos images
mais aussi notre finesse de perception
et de saisie dans ce modèle en trois
dimensions derrière ses lunettes
polarisantes Caren est une spécialiste
détachée de l'Institut national de
l'information géographique et forestière
l'hygiène est arrivée ici en tant que
expert de la photogrammétrie et de la
restitution aujourd'hui on forme tous
les nouveaux restituteurs donc
militaires et puis on assure aussi
l'expertise au sein de tous les acteurs
qui ont besoin de nos modèles en trois
dimensions on travaille à 80% pour le
Centre national de ciblage ou nos
modèles sont rentrés dans le guide
terminal du missile et puis on a aussi
les théâtres qui ont besoin de nos
points de nos coordonnées très précis
mais aussi des fois de modèles 3D sur le
théâtre ou en deux dimensions cette
présence d'experts de l'hygiène découle
de plusieurs marchés passés avec
l'organisme ils incluent la présence de
personnels l'acquisition de
cartographies du territoire national et
l'impression en masse qui permettrait en
cas d'engagement majeur de pouvoir
alimenter les troupes françaises et
alliées
cependant pour les petites commandes le
GI dispose de capacités internes au sein
de son dépôt géographique un hangar de
3000 mètres carrés dédié notamment au
stockage quelques 2 millions 500 000
cartes sont entreposés dans les allées
du bâtiment et 130 000 produits sont
répertoriés dans le patrimoine de
référence
c'est également ici que l'on prépare les
commandes
sont contrôlés
l'intégrité du document
un passage rapide sur chaque carte
puisque l'impression est conforme je
prends mon beurre de retravail et je
contrôle les quantités
sont à disposition pour compléter les
stocks en une journée 5000 cartes
résistantes à l'eau peuvent être
imprimés pour l'impression d'une carte
classique en format A0 un mètre par un
mètre suivant la charge de couleur il
faut compter entre une à deux minutes
pour le tirage
en moyenne chaque année 1200 commandes
sont réalisées et 160 000 cartes
distribués qu'il s'agisse de cartes
aéronautiques de cartes de camp
nationaux ou encore de cartes de pays où
les soldats français sont engagés
les clients proviennent des unités des
trois armées de la sécurité civile de la
gendarmerie nationale des douanes ou
encore de certains pays alliés
l'établissement représente d'ailleurs la
voie de la France dans le domaine de la
géographie auprès de l'OTAN et participe
régulièrement à des groupes de travail
en 2020 toute la chaîne de production de
l'EGI a pu mettre sa réactivité à
l'épreuve
le 4 août depuis 100 explosion secoue le
port de Beyrouth au Liban provoquant
l'effondrement de nombreux bâtiments
la France déclenche alors l'opération
amitié 1200 tonnes de fraises
humanitaire sont acheminées ainsi que
750 militaires pour faciliter leur
déploiement l'établissement a dû
remettre à jour la cartographie du site
vous voyez ici au niveau de du centre de
la carte on voit les stigmates je dirais
de l'explosion qui sont juste ici juste
après l'explosion donc on avait récupéré
l'image assez récente on avait habillé
mise en forme imprimée et envoyé là de
la carte est un peu particulière c'est
une carte qui a été partagée avec les
Libanais sur place où on a un carrelage
au bataille navale avec un code couleur
ce qui permettait quand ils avaient des
comptes-rendus à faire de dire ok ben je
suis en F2 et en rouge ça veut dire
qu'ils étaient dans cette partie là de
la carte à partir d'images satellitaires
le GI actualisera en 72 heures son fond
cartographique 5 kg de cartes seront
imprimés et expédiés
au même moment d'autres spécialistes
s'activaient dans le port libanais une
petite équipe du service hydrographique
et océanographique de la marine de
plongeurs des mineurs effectuer une
reconnaissance des fonds
de façon tout à fait complémentaire il
s'agissait d'assurer la sécurité du
porte et l'hélicoptère amphibie qui
devait entrer dans le port donc il y
avait tant de débris au fond du port que
il n'était pas raisonnable de faire
entrer ce bâtiment conséquent qui a
porté la logistique de le faire rentrer
dans le port sans préalablement vérifier
les fonds et donc la première opération
j'allais dire de ce porte hélicoptère à
l'arrivée ça a été de déployer des
moyens et une équipe de d'officiers
mariniers hydrographe du chôm pour faire
cette clarification ce besoin est allé
au-delà cette couverture ces travaux
elle est au-delà il s'agissait aussi de
rouvrir au trafic maritime l'accès aux
ports pour le pour les pour les civils
aussi
en temps normal la principale mission du
chaume établissement public sous tutelle
du ministère des armées consiste à
assurer la description et la prévision
des océans du large au littoral il
garantit en quelque sorte la continuité
en mer de ce que fait le GI le chaume
collect traite archives et diffuse
l'information géographique maritime
grâce à des moyens dédiés comme par
exemple le système déployable
d'hydrographie militaire le sdhm utilisé
au Liban
on va effectuer un
bâtisseillarimètre donc ça va nous
permettre de mesurer la vitesse du son
dans l'eau sur toute la colonne d'eau
dans les différentes couches d'eau
c'est une donnée nécessaire pour notre
sondeur afin de bien corriger les
trajets acoustiques et de bien
positionner les sondes
le système doté d'un sonar est utilisé
pour faire des relevés de plage en
anticipation d'opération amphibie des
levées pour ouvrir de nouvelles voies de
navigation ou encore pour lever des
doutes face à de potentiels dangers
sous-marins invisibles à l’œil peut y
avoir une roche qui a fleur un mètre
sous la surface mais on la voit pas et
le seul moyen de le voir c'est de passer
avec des systèmes comme le sdhm sur des
zones encadrillant méthodiquement la
zone à traiter il collecte les données
nécessaires pour ensuite réaliser une
cartographie précise c'est un système
qui est relativement simple de mise en
oeuvre puisqu'il s'est il est comme je
disais donc à héros transportable
modulable et surtout il s'adapte sur
tout type d'embarcation donc assez
légère donc là nous sommes sur un
Zodiaque qui fait 5 mètres 50 de
longueur
et partout nous propose d'aller sonner
on s'adapte par rapport à l'embarcation
que l'on perçoit
dans un contexte de maritimisation du
monde et d'innovation technologique la
connaissance de l'environnement à la
surface et sous la surface des océans
est un facteur décisif pour nos
opérations les zones de déploiement de
la Marine en quelques années son passé
de 40 millions de kilomètres carrés à 60
millions donc qui représente 6 fois la
zone économique exclusive donc nous
sommes susceptibles d'avoir des des
soutiens sur cette zone très étendue
[Musique]
les produits fournis par le chaume
permettent au bâtiment de naviguer en
sécurité aux forces navales de se
déployer sur toutes les mers du monde et
au sous-marins d'opérer en toute
discrétion des données également
primordiales pour mieux comprendre le
rôle de l'océan dans la régulation du
climat et appréhender les évolutions à
venir
effectivement
haute latitude c'est connu il y a des
modifications des masses d'eau donc
c'est un point qui nécessite du coût de
mettre à jour notre connaissance et
notamment notre connaissance je dirais
saisonnière puisque aujourd'hui c'est ça
comme pour la météo encore une fois il y
a l'équivalent de saison dans dans
l'océan et là il y a des modifications
qui sont du fait du changement
climatique avec la création du dépôt des
cartes plan et journaux de la Marine en
1720 la France est le premier état à se
doter d'un service hydrographique
national elle continue de nos jours à
adapter ses moyens pour répondre aux
nouveaux enjeux environnementaux et
géopolitiques
le parfum du miel et des conifères sur
la terre ferme cette fois nous
rejoignons la seule unité militaire
topographique et cartographique de
France à agnaux en Alsace
le 28e groupe géographique appartient au
commandement du renseignement de l'armée
de terre au quotidien il met à jour la
carte graphie de référence des forces et
représente un appui précieux pour le
commandement nous avons en permanence
des cartographes dans les états majeurs
opérationnels et en plus de ça nous
engageons régulièrement des détachements
topographiques en appui des unités pour
répondre à des besoins spécifiques
pendant plusieurs années des experts ont
notamment été déployés au Mali dans le
cadre de l'opération barkhane
par exemple pour réaliser la
cartographie du bassin du Niger pour
mettre en place des repères géodésiques
qui permettent ensuite de positionner
correctement les images satellites pour
créer des repères d'orientation pour
l'artillerie ou par exemple des modèles
de terrain qui permettent ensuite au
génie de réaliser
les travaux d'infrastructures sur les
bases
le groupe dispose de son propre centre
de formation il reçoit en moyenne 80
sous-officiers et officiers stagiaires
parents
ne va compiler que les données qui sont
dans votre logiciel
les savoir-faire classique d'un
topographe civil sont adaptés aux
spécificités de l'engagement
opérationnel et des matériaux utilisés
des équipements qui ont fortement évolué
depuis quelques années c'est ce que nous
allons constater habite exercice c'est
de réaliser l'ensemble des missions
d'appui oppositionnement et de
caractérisation du terrain qu'il faut
servir aux autres unités donc à cet
effet voici vos missions donc 10 le
détachement du capitaine Bastien le
connaît bien en effet le 28e groupe
géographique est responsable de la
réalisation de toutes les cartes des
camps militaires français ce que vous
avez des questions sur vos missions
aujourd'hui chaque équipe de topographe
va déployer des capteurs différents et
complémentaires
ici c'est un drone destiné à la
cartographie qui va être utilisée le
rapace 3D
[Musique]
ça va nous permettre de créer des
modèles 3D des images à jour précises
résolues sur les zones d'intérêt alors
vraiment en fait c'est une elfix comparé
à la plupart des drones auxquels on a
l'habitude de voir des quadricoptères
ici on est sur Netflix ça va nous
permettre d'avoir une grande autonomie
avec ce drone on arrive à voler jusqu'à
1h15 d'autonomie sur nos zones d'action
il reste malgré tout léger il pèse un
kilo 6
l'appareil peut donner une précision
allant jusqu'à 2 cm et sa technologie
embarquée lui permet d'atterrir sur de
très courtes distances
non loin de là un drone aquatique équipé
d'unar effectue des levées
hydrographiques
un nouvel outil qui va s'avérer très
utile pour les unités du génie notamment
pour les franchissements de cours d'eau
ou de fleuves par exemple
on faisait ça avec un zodiaque
on tenait en tendait une corde avec des
nœuds matériaux par des distances à
chaque pneu on produit un point GPS et
on prenait une sonde avec un sondeur
manuel et on bonissait de bonbons comme
ça donnerait
[Musique]
tout le monde en fait
un gain de sécurité aussi vital sur les
théâtres d'opération
un autre équipement permet également de
ne pas exposer l'opérateur le système
léger de topographie une structure reçue
récemment capable de s'intégrer sur tous
les véhicules tactiques de l'unité son
capteur laser piloté depuis l'habitacle
enregistre un million de points à la
seconde ça c'est le nuage de points que
prend le Dida donc là on parle le toit
qui se forme là du bâtiment ça c'est le
bâtiment et là c'est la route
la précision des données peut par
exemple permettre de planifier le
passage d'un convoi
en condition opérationnelle jusqu'à 300
km pourrait être à qui chaque jour
nous avons toute une gamme de capteurs
très moderne qui permettent d'accélérer
ou d'avoir un gain de temps en
phénoménal sur le traitement des données
ou de faire des rendus très
technologiques qui permettent d'apporter
une certaine innovation dans ses
savoir-faire finalement assez ancestraux
parmi ces capteurs on retrouve également
un véhicule d'appui topographique doté
d'une centrale inertielle
lors d'une action de brouillage elle
permettrait aux VAP de s'affranchir de
la connexion GPS pour connaître sa
position et déterminer celle des unités
amis
il existe aussi ce scanner laser
terrestre qui permet lui une acquisition
en 3D à 360 degrés en quelques minutes
le recueil d'informations est une
première étape elle doivent ensuite être
traitées
j'ai la clé ne sujet la base j'ai les
statiques nous sommes dans un camion dit
groupe exploitation de calcul donc ce
camion nous permet d'être mobile de
pouvoir nous déplacer avec les équipes
topographiques
et il va nous permettre d'être autonome
donc on est autonome en électricité avec
un groupe électrogène et on est autonome
au niveau des ordinateurs ce qui nous
permet de suivre les équipes de post
traité directement le soir le travail
des équipes nous travaillons aussi au
profit d'unité très diverses en
particulier l'artillerie qui a des gros
besoins en termes de positionnement et
d'orientation nous sommes donc aptes
alors fournir des positions connues sans
nécessairement leur fournir de cartes
même si la carte reste un produit qui
est très demandé puisque le plus le plus
parlant pour l'aide à la décision c'est
pour ça que nos équipes travaillent
constamment pour mettre à jour à partir
du terrain les données ou les
informations qui apparaissent dans les
cartes pour qu'elles soient le plus à
jour possible
et j'emmène les travaux des équipes
topographiques avec l'ensemble des
points levés sur le terrain merci
le dernier maillon de cette chaîne
géographique projetable se trouve dans
ce camion ou deux spécialistes
exploitent les données pour en faire des
cartes papier ou numériques
je passe sur la mise en page
occupe pas du coup des bâtiments et
après je retombe sur les routes
à l'intérieur il dispose également d'une
capacité d'impression identique à ce que
l'on pourrait retrouver en état-major
nous venons de le voir les produits
réalisés au sein des armées sont
nombreux une fois vérifié et intégrés au
patrimoine de référence il faut les
rendre accessibles et c'est une des
missions de la cellule web services de
l'établissement géographique inter-armé
j'ai récupéré une donnée qui fait partie
d'un grand programme et ce que je suis
en train de faire c'est que je suis en
train de la mettre en forme pour ensuite
la publier sur nos serveurs une fois que
ce sera sur nos serveurs ça va
directement être accessible à tous nos
utilisateurs en même temps à savoir
qu'on a 2500 utilisateurs environ et que
c'est en train d'augmenter assez
rapidement c'est à dire qu'on est deux
trois utilisateurs en plus par jour
grâce aux nouvelles technologies ce
service va évoluer avec l'arrivée du
programme d'armement Géode 4D
il a pour objectif de mettre à
disposition des forces armées les
données produits et services des
différents domaines d'environnement
géophysique que sont la géographie
l'hydrographie l'océanographie et la
météorologie pour ça il s'appuie sur
deux composantes un composante système
d'information qui permet de rationaliser
les nombreux systèmes en service et une
composante production externalisée de
données géographiques qui permet de
produire un nombre un volume important
de donner géographiques donc ça peut
être des cartes ça peut être des plans
de ville ça peut être des modèles
numériques de terrain la mise en service
opérationnelle de la partie système
d'information est prévu à compter de
2023 cet outil permettra de visualiser
commander et télécharger les données
sans avoir besoin de faire une demande
vers l'établissement géographique
interarmé pour le volet production de
données le défi à relever réside dans
l'amélioration de la productivité de la
réactivité la DGA soutient l'innovation
à travers différents dispositifs
financiers elle met en oeuvre par
exemple les dispositifs d'intelligence
artificielle qui permettent de faire de
la détection de l'identification
d'objets
issus d'images satellites par exemple ou
de mettre en œuvre des dispositifs de
détection de changement qui permettront
d'améliorer la mise à jour des produits
c'est tout l'enjeu de creasmap ce projet
vise à proposer une solution pour la
reconstruction automatique de scène
terrestre en 3D très précise à partir
d'images satellites l'objectif étant de
pouvoir détecter rapidement des éléments
d'intérêt comme des routes des bâtiments
des arbres et pour cela la Direction
générale de l'armement a fait appel à
trois experts CS groupe l'INRIA et la
société Luke carta porteuse du projet
basée dans la technopôle de Nice Sophia
Antipolis
donc nous on a une forte expertise da on
a développé notre propre modèle et
ensuite on utilise riche catalogue de
Luke carda pour entraîner ce modèle sur
des centaines de villes ceci permet
avoir des modèles qui peuvent
fonctionner partout dans le monde avec
de très bonnes performances ces
technologies représentent un avantage
considérable aujourd'hui les
technologies spatiales également
évoluent très rapidement donc on peut
avoir les images
prises par de satellites avec très haute
fréquences partout dans le monde et
grâce à nos outils on peut partir de ces
images on peut les convertir en données
géographique cette capacité permettrait
ainsi d'avoir une vision quasi immédiate
sur un événement spécifique comme une
catastrophe naturelle et de réagir très
vite mais un autre domaine intéresse
aussi les forces ça te permet vraiment
de révolutionner le domaine de
simulation parce que ça permet à voir
donc notre monde qui est réel qui passe
synthétique et pas virtuel mais donc
dans les simulations virtuelle ce qui
permet de faire des entraînements déjà
avec des seins beaucoup plus riches pour
mener ces travaux Luke carta a pu
bénéficier du dispositif d'appui à
l'innovation de la DGA
il y a vraiment une dynamique
entrepreneuriale de la part des armées
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une volonté
d'aller l'avant une volonté de
travailler avec des
petites boîtes de les faire accélérer
dans un rapport de partenariat ça veut
vraiment être un accélérateur de
croissance au niveau de nos effectifs de
rêver on est passé de 5 ou 6 personnes à
18 maintenant c'est quand même c'est pas
c'est pas rien à notre échelle et les
ambitions de la société ne s'arrêtent
pas là la vision
à moyen long terme de Luc sympa c'est
d'être vraiment un champion français et
européen dans le traitement de données
satellitaires pour en faire la
cartographie précise récente très rapide
pour pouvoir déployer cette cartographie
a besoin si besoin et on
s'affranchissant de un maximum de
contraintes administratives techniques
etc et ça a de la valeur
pour les utilisateurs qui peut être
l'armée en discutablement
dans un contexte de retour des rapports
de force entre les états de guerre
hybride et de poursuites de la lutte
contre le terrorisme la maîtrise de
l'environnement est un facteur de
puissance
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier la
géographie militaire garantit la liberté
d'action et la supériorité
opérationnelle des armées françaises
[Musique]